guys yeah radar still very active
temperatures of course warmer than
yesterday as we saw more sunshine more
sunshine means we get to cook up the
atmosphere a little more and allow
storms to develop we also have some
gusty winds at times i'd say gusts
between 20 to 30 as we do have some
nearby thunderstorms that are giving us
those outflow winds here's the latest on
the radar this new cell just popped up
east of sunrise manor and just west of
i'd say valley of fire this is some
lightning strikes detected with this not
over the las vegas valley those showers
near red rocks starting to dissipate
there and the new cell also develop
right down your way up to indian springs
right along i'd say the near indian
springs on your way up to mount
charleston to turn off there looking
outside right now a lot of moisture a
lot of storms still working around the
region your evening planners showing
guess what slight chances at least until
sundown and a warm evening coming up
what's in store for us tomorrow i'll
have that all coming up christian